Hi my name is Reece I'm a councillor for
the villages Ward at Thanet District
Council. One of the reasons why I wanted
to be a councillor was that I wanted to
effect positive change in my local area
and make sure that residents concerns
and views were heard at district council
level. If you want to be a
councillor, if you want to stand up for
the views and the rights of your
community and the residents around you
then please do stand to be a
councillor. It's an absolutely
fantastic role to do, it's a great
opportunity - you learn so so much. It's just it is amazing it is
amazing and what I would say is
that we need more young people
here and we need the new young
generation of councillors to come in and
to bring a bit of life into this chamber
and ensure that this council is
prepared for the future.
So if you're young and you're
dedicated and you love where you live
and you want it to remain the wonderful
place that is then please consider
standing as a councillor.